everyone knows that professional cs go
faced something of a mass exodus during
the so-called online era players were
leaving in droves to take up valorant in
an effort to in some cases
salvage their careers magnum's in the
smoke here oh my god magnum's got no hp
not like this sentinels they're gonna
get the defuse they've done it sentinels
are the masters to reikovic champions
even some old heads made the switch for
a chance to not only prove that they
still had it but to take one last shot
at a title shadow's good for wine we go
go trade's one
chronicle
has plenty of health chronicle on the
tap
he's got it rose don't fake he's got to
get it to happen
however the bulk of these stories are
centered around north america you see
nacs really struggled to make ends meet
during this time so there was this huge
incentive for players to give the riot
ip a shot in fact in the early stages of
competitive valorant it seemed like
every roster worth watching was composed
of former cs gopros now across the
atlantic eu counter-strike
indestructible as it is
was facing its own set of issues tier
one teams weren't pulling out of a
competitive scene but with spots on top
rosters being limited some veteran
players were struggling to find
opportunities and for them valorent
wasn't just some easy fix to the problem
i'm aware of the conditions
of cs right now and what coveted and
online season is impacting the scene in
general right now i'm not causing any
dose that's what i'm saying i'm not
taking decisions once again i have time
to think about things and i have a list
of party i have in my head and what i'm
saying is that valuing is not my
priority right now but amidst this
torrid uncertain time for european
counter-strike where even the most
seasoned strikers had no idea what was
in their best interest
there was one household name who did
fully commit to the switch
well
sort of you see there's a certain
storied french professional whose
experiences during the online era were a
little different compared to the general
confusion and uncertainty most faced i
am of course talking about nathan nbk
schmidt the bearded beauty with sweet
doughy eyes who just might be the
linchpin for french cs it's gonna be in
for a bit of a tight time here nicely
done point blank finds one gets a sec a
third looking for it he gets the fourth
as well
french cs
nbk
despite being regarded as his region's
so-called king maker in cs go nbk
decided to make the jump to valorant in
an attempt to refresh his competitive
career the thing is
he never actually played it
at least not for a professional team nbk
spent over six months of his life just
streaming valorent and then
seemingly out of nowhere he came back to
cs and underwent a staggering
renaissance kingdom towards lobby
contact at door it's going to be nbk
dupree shows a shoulder great double
kill it is old nuke nbk with a stunning
triple the question on everybody's mind
is
how
how has the natural-born killer been
blessed with the craziest instance of
what the community has termed the
so-called valorant buff what did
becoming more in tune with his mental
health do to change how he views himself
as a competitor and why in god's name
was his magnificent return
suddenly cut short well i thought mbk
was actually playing much better than
what i would have given him credit for i
think you think he was looking pretty
good it's it's very weird it does show
that somewhere along the lines mouse
kind of [ __ ] up because otherwise it
doesn't really make that much sense
all right so in order to fully
appreciate nbk's storied counter-strike
career we need to go back to global
offensive's oft memed predecessor
counter-strike source now sure there
were a lot of cs go pros that got their
start in source and of course 1.6 but
it's important to remember that nbk
wasn't just cutting his teeth he was
playing for one of the most successful
source teams of all time
very games nbk mom on his back takes on
shocks as he pushed up caught him just
in time
going for the bomb plant it's gonna be a
safe plant so it's 11 to nine in favor
of a nexus though nbk looking to back up
trying to find a good spot as he takes
down smiz with a headshot as he peeked
up through the brick and he gets the
third one on to scream nbk played
alongside other eventual french cs
legends such as rpk kenny s apex and
shaksi and together they won over 20
tournaments cementing themselves as
sources greatest ever team but as i'm
sure many of you are well aware the
success
they didn't stop after that after making
the jump to cs go very games quickly
established themselves as a top tier
roster and nbk's impressive performances
throughout 2013 earned him recognition
as one of the game's best players
2-1 now in terms of personnel versus pro
have the advantage into the bomb site
they go nice smoke to cover mbk they've
already gone in for the defuse here i
think as well but nbk has got the first
one can he get the second one here it's
against guardian they dance around the
box and pay a bit of peekaboo which way
round is it it's right hand sided it's
nbk
here's the thing though while things did
look to be heading in a positive
direction on the server
the same
couldn't be said for vari games off the
server at the end of 2013 the org
announced that it was being dissolved
due to financial struggles which saw nbk
join titan for the better part of 2014
but it was only after he joined smith's
on a project that would become ldlc that
he truly began to earn his kingmaker
status then bk spotted the ball out but
there's the man's brand he drops the
ball carrier taz is gone nbk with the
double kill of the seasons alongside
shocks happy and kiyoshima ldlc took
csgo's competitive scene by storm and at
dreamhack winter 2014 they made history
by securing france's first ever cs go
major after the high of the win all eyes
were back on french cs ldlc would get
picked up by envious and the seed that
nbk had planted continued to bear fruit
in the form of another major title at
dreamhack cluj-napoca 2015 but the winds
themselves didn't carry a lot of weight
for nbk at least not for long for him it
was about the relationships that these
titles had helped him engender if you
win a major you're happy for a week
you take it a bit longer and then you're
done and then you move on to something
else and you want to win more at the end
of the day everything that i've won
means nothing it brought me so much in
terms of lifestyle
friends opportunities everything but it
doesn't rule what i do on a daily basis
come 2017 nbk kenny s and apex were
signed by g2 esports to form a french
super team with body and shocks and
while the roster did find some early
success it wasn't long before cracks
began to form you see anyone who's
familiar with the french counter-strike
scene knows that for many many years it
developed a sort of reputation for
internal drama players didn't mesh well
together play styles were criticized and
often people were singled out for poor
tournament results he was basically an
fps driven soap opera fueled by the
pettiest of storylines cs teams are such
a tight group probably five players a
coach a manager it's like seven persons
if you have problems between two persons
that are that start getting deep then
the team can easily get screwed after
getting benched by g2 in june of 2018
nbk was picked up by vitality later that
year there he reunited with some
familiar faces to build a winning roster
around cs go's most impossibly explosive
up-and-comer xaiwu and once again nbk
put his regal magic to work only two
players are left alive for vitality they
can only trade but only
becomes something very big as mpk gets a
free man spray down only menis alive in
one v one and b k knows where he is they
know each other's position but ibk wins
it is 12 to 11. oh he's absolutely ready
look at mpk actually gets caught out
this thing
picks up a double like lightning out of
the sky
comes in with a triple for mouse sports
is back to a 404 but mbk is still
standing by at new corner he will get
free will get a form as well over the
course of the next year vitality
provided csgo fans with moments of
brilliance and while nbk continued to
prove that he was very capable of
fragging he retained his passion for
team building unfortunately it was that
very passion that led nbk to get benched
again was that a really really tough
call to make considering you and you and
mbk actually have to build this team and
then get back to that point of being
competitive again was that a tough
decision to make
well obviously yes
it became me i played together for
four years i guess before i got removed
from the team and that wasn't easy to to
do that obviously it was the team choice
and not only mine uh we had like some
bubbles to be uh to be agree on on many
things uh uh i know
how to build the team and how to getting
better after his departure from vitality
nbk had stints with og and then double
pony but despite being a two-time major
winner he couldn't find a team that
offered him a chance to reach the top
again yeah i think i received some
offers from different teams but nothing
that was that was really convinced about
joining straight away like it was none
of the
top tier teams or like teams that had
the potential to be among the very best
trades so i just um i just took my time
to
potentially find the right place but at
that time it didn't come but
there was another option a way to start
again remain competitive and perhaps
find the same glory he once did and that
option
was valerent so on june 29th of 2021 nbk
announced that he was making the move it
is time for a change
did it suck to see such a natural-born
killer leave counter-strike of course
but the hope was that he was finally
gonna get a fresh start he'd join a tier
one team work his magic for the
millionth time and show these mickey
mouse rosters how you really build a
squad now until he could do that the
plan was to take a stab at content
creation and prove to everyone that
while valorent may be a different game
he was very much still the same nbk
enemy remaining
you can revive me sage
one enemy remaining
plus
fans were waiting with baited breath for
nbk to be swooped up by a tier one
valeran team but
months went by
and an announcement never came former cs
pros were selling like hotcakes so why
was a player with such a pedigree still
a free agent well as it turns out it was
mostly by design for veterans um
it was slightly different i really
wanted to take them to take time at the
beginning to just get familiar with the
game and playing a lot of solo queue and
really having that good basis of a
player really get there and you know
feel comfortable with the game and be a
good player and not just the guy that
transitioned and came in with his
background the offers came a bit later
for like interesting and good teams
but uh but yeah the main point was
taking my time and not rushing getting
into a new contract uh just
for the sake of having a contract in
addition to just wanting to master the
basics of valorant before diving in
whole hog nbk was also looking inward
and discovering more about himself both
as a person and as a player and on
january 3rd 2022 he disclosed via
twitter that he'd recently been
diagnosed on the autism spectrum this
discovery helped nbk understand his past
professional relationships better but it
also gave him insight into how he might
develop his future ones
my place as a player coach and the
impact that i could have with the people
around me is what's going to be the most
affected by it in the sense that i know
my strengths and weaknesses through
scientific experiments if you want to
like people knowing and like research
and all of that stuff you know when you
know what the obstacles are it's way
easier to go around them but if you walk
in the dark and you don't know what's
before you then it's very hard to like
anticipate and know how to work on some
things and whatnot and that's kind of
the same idea where by knowing myself
better on how i approach certain
subjects my relationships with emotions
with other human beings
it makes it way easier to find ways to
trick yourself or to
make everything work despite those
problems while nbk's revelation was met
with a torrent of support across the
esports community he gave fans a reason
to rejoice when he further announced his
return to cs go i have brought many
teams to the top
and i'm ready to do it again most of us
heaved a giant sigh of relief at this
news
i mean would it have been fun to watch
nbk's [ __ ] on some overwatch players in
valorant
sure but this is the natural-born killer
we're talking about the man belongs in
counter-strike this is a guy who was
clapping cheeks with the source deagle
and winning cs go majors while prodigies
like municy were still in diapers cs was
his home
but and this was the question of course
after such an extended break from
counter-strike would even a legend like
nbk
really be able to come back
the same quality of player it's no
secret that valorant is extremely
similar to counter-strike it is a 5v5
diffusal tax shooter every weapon is a
dupe and there's a heavy emphasis on
utility but there are some important
differences for starters movement is
considerably slower in ballarat you know
barring some obvious exceptions it feels
like agents are wading through molasses
with cement blocks for shoes
or should i back out
bro we're obviously walking i don't know
why you're doing that
on top of that the gun play feels
a lot different there are no set spray
patterns for guns which ends up being
one of the hardest things for cs go
players to
overcome oh oh
no
yeah he's very used to cs with the crowd
spray but against all expectations nbk
came back to cs go with a vengeance as
if he'd somehow been
buffed by valorant and even though mouse
had brought him in to play a much more
structured support role apparently his
time away from counter-strike had given
him an insatiable thirst for blood get
stuck in but he is going forward instant
instantly dead and there you have it mbk
will close down the round with three to
his name it's three high explosive
grenades
um his head but
instead just keeps taking him he is
going to take him the king maker beheads
another
and two more in his crosshairs just
breaking that give him to him course
he's not going to be expecting this i
don't think he's dead he is dead
oh
mbk the savior so
how did nbk seamlessly transition from
streaming a hero shooter to competing in
tier 1 european cs
without missing a beat like
surely the valorant buff is just
a meme
right and so you environment the the
main thing is you have to have cleaner
aim in a way you can uh you can spray
less so maybe maybe there's some trip to
that then you come back and
counterstrike it and you have to be
cleaner in the way you're aiming but
yeah i'm i'm not 100 certain about about
the truth of it if it's a recording
theme then you know
it might uh it might be truth and while
it was an obvious bonus for mows that
nbk was stepping up and filling the
fragging void left by rops that's not
why he'd been recruited he'd been
brought in for his experience leadership
and vision something mouse had sorely
been lacking prior to his arrival
although expectations for nbk or even
mouse at large might not have been high
from the get-go fans hoped to see a
feisty fairly competitive roster that
had aspirations to grow and that's
exactly what they looked like they were
getting well that is of course until
mouz announced
shockingly out of nowhere right after
our interview with nbk that he was being
moved to the bench in favor of an
upcoming prospect yeah i think that's
kind of like why he got shafted by this
entire announcement i think miles really
[ __ ] up with the wording and generally
just with the with the way that they
communicated this but obviously like you
brought in nbk for for a different
reason than foreign it's pretty clear
that they wanted him to bring in some
sort of a leadership and so for them to
to come out with this
pr where it was something like we really
appreciate jdc's positivity and attitude
and you're like
players from across the community chimed
in with their two cents about this kind
of bizarre decision and the confusion
was in a sense warranted as
statistically speaking nbk had been
performing above expectation mouse
claimed it had to do with poor results
at pro league but they placed fourth in
a difficult group and beat major
runner-up
super team g2 in the process so to say
that nbk was blindsided by the decision
would be an understatement as of right
now it isn't entirely clear what the
rest of 2022 holds for nbk's competitive
future professional cs go is a cut
throat business and sadly it's affected
nbk more than most despite the fact that
he's one of the most influential players
his region has ever produced if you want
to look at it on like a global
perspective i could stop counter-strike
tomorrow and be very satisfied and have
a better career than the 95 99
of players that are in this game right
but uh to me the main point is to be
able to enjoy again what i do on a daily
basis for now it looks as though nbk is
going to keep his sights set on cs go
and just wait until the opportunity to
step into the spotlight presents itself
yet again
but if recent form is any indication
the natural-born killer still has plenty
left to give
nbk get your gun out guz does have it
out crosstalk
and nbk makes it count
rekills for the frenchman
so
how did nbk effortless effort
effortlessly i can't say this word
effortlessly it's weird because there's
like no words in english that i can't
say but this is the only one it tops the
list i can't say effortlessly
effortlessly
effortlessly
not not effortless i'll tell you that
much man